John McCain this summer has been running
a very humorous campaign basically
complaining that Barack Obama his
Democratic opponent is being treated
like a rock star by not just celebrities
but also by the media who worship his
every move this is ironic for several
reasons not least of which is the fact
that over the last quarter century no
Republican in national politics in
America has come close to receiving the
kind of favorable media treatment that
McCain has this is for a variety of
reasons one of which is that during the
Keating five scandal of the late 80s and
early 90s John McCain was at his sort of
political ebb he realized that he just
sits back and answers every single
question that a journalist asks suddenly
he's going to get more favorable
treatment he's used that approach ever
since except for the last few months
interestingly that's one reason another
reason is that for a long time in many
reporters who covered him in addition to
being very charmed by the access that he
gives them they're not used to hanging
out with Republicans who they find
copacetic and they're certainly not used
to hang around with military veterans
and their double triple certainly not
used to hang around with military
veterans who happen to have been
tortured in prison for five and a half
years in Vietnam so he has this sort of
magical effect and in the late 90s and
early 2000s he also was choosing one by
one issues that journalists care about
and that his own party does not if
there's anything that reporters like
besides access it's a politician going
after his own party particularly when
that party is the Republican Party and
so this has been the case with campaign
finance reform the late 90s when he was
going after Big Tobacco and even now as
he goes after you know big oil and oil
speculators he is playing to a media
base the great irony in all of this is
that this is allowed McCain to be had a
huge national profile on Tim Russert you
know more than 50 times on Jon Stewart
more than any single politician but now
that he's running against a guy who
sounds an awful lot like John McCain and
tooth
and he's beginning to realize that it's
not very fun to be on the receiving end
of it